[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
spring and charles barkley hall of famer
inside the nba on tnt analyst how much
are you following what's going on in the
nfl cam going back to the panthers obj
going to the rams
come on dan you know football i bet on
football every saturday and sunday i got
to keep up with what's happening all
week
how are you doing gambling this year
uh
i've been doing pretty good in college
pros has been up and down all over the
place
but hey we got a long way to go dan i'm
not gonna run out of money no time soon
uh how big is your bookies house
uh we've never met oh you haven't
no okay
you just
hey to cover my ass i have a go-between
oh okay all right yeah yeah yeah just in
case they get him
i don't know how big his house is but
all right listen hey i told that's the
same thing i don't see i've never done
an email
i've never done any social media i told
you dad all these people going to learn
if you're going to talk bad about people
do it the old-fashioned way behind their
back
uh like markeith morris didn't he he
sort of did it behind the joker's back
yeah dan uh i was disappointed in the
nba on that you know i'm a big fan of
the mark brothers but that was a cheap
shot
i'm glad joker defended himself you just
can't hit somebody
first of all if you hit somebody you
should never turn your back on
that's why like people say you hit him
in the back i'm like wait you hit me and
you turn your back
hey
i can be sure one thing if you hit me
and you turn your back i'm gonna hit you
in the back of the head
okay you guys just you and shaq came up
on the anniversary of you
taking the ball and bouncing off shaq's
head and then you guys had your
wrestling match did you guys celebrate
that anniversary
no i actually didn't know it was our
anniversary yeah because we moved we
yeah we moved to tuesday nights now
so i don't i didn't uh so i'm adjusting
to the tuesday schedule but hey dan
that's just a perfect example
like i'm not gonna fight jack he's too
big but if somebody hit me in front of
20 000 people i'm gonna act like i'm
gonna fight
like he might hit me one or two times or
i might hit him hit him one or two times
but it's not like we're gonna fight for
five minutes straight they're gonna
break it up quickly but i'm not gonna
let anybody hit me in front of 20 000
people and not do anything
shaq had a left that if it connected you
might still be down charles
dan you act like i can't take a punch
i've been hit before but but not by shaq
come on man stop it all right give me
give me somebody that hits you that like
i'd be like wow and you
well i mean
i'm not gonna get on here and talk a lot
of noise but i think it's probably hard
to knock somebody out with one punch i
mean you can get hit with a flurry of
punches and get knocked out but i think
there's very few people
who can hit a person
with one shot even great boxers i mean
you know box is one of my favorite
sports but
you know ali frazier foreman
norton shavers
holmes
pacquiao floyd i mean i don't remember i
mean george foreman even when he beat
frazier
he hit him like a thousand times but joe
frazier kept getting up and george
arguably one of the greatest hitters of
all punches of all time you don't think
shaq would have knocked you out with
that left
i do not okay
that don't mean he couldn't hurt me a
little bit but i don't think he could
knock me out
uh i see you're flying the colors for
auburn there so how excited are you that
cam newton is uh going back to carolina
well i'm glad cam got a job you know he
wanted to play i saw him uh a couple
weeks ago at the auburn georgia game
and uh uh he we he i got a lot of love
for cam i mean it's gonna be interesting
though i don't i don't know is how
successful joining a uh nfl team in the
middle of the season yeah i mean that's
got to be a very difficult thing
uh but i'm glad he got a job because i
pulled up a cam he's a good man what are
those shoes behind you underneath the
your dream team jersey or
um so this flag is probably one of my
most valuable possessions i stole this
from the olympics in 92
and it's got everybody who was on the
original dream team on it
that's the first dream team i got
everybody to sign this flag that's
probably when i sell my memorabilia for
underprivileged housing it's probably
going to be to get the most money yeah
but
i i'm in my gym trophy room bar pool
table room
and i got a jersey from everybody on the
second dream team
uh sign
and a pair of shoes under the jersey and
now that's uh penny hardaway's right
there
i got uh karmalone
uh
scotty pippin john stockton
elijahwan peyton mine red mitch richmond
grant hill reggie miller got a bunch of
great stuff over my career but i'm gonna
sell all this crap for underprivileged
houses in my hometown since we get
through the pandemic
help me understand what's going through
scottie pippen's mind right now
hey you need dr phil
you need everybody you know
i feel bad because it seems like he's
just trying to go big game hunting
because he's selling a book
uh i'm never gonna tell another person
what to say we gotta all have our own
opinion
but this seems like he's got a book
coming out
because
the book when when you write a book
in my opinion it should be your personal
thoughts about everything about you you
letting the world know what you think
uh but it just seems like to me when you
go after phil jackson michael jordan
he came out to me a little bit you're
just going big game hunting because
you know it's gonna get some clicks
and uh i've always liked scotty i
thought he was a very good player
but like i say it just seems like
i've just got to go big game hunting
because if i talk bad about big time
people it's gonna get clicks and i'm
gonna sell some books
i feel bad for him because it felt like
nobody really asked him his opinion when
he played i remember being around the
bulls the nba finals and it felt like it
was mike it was phil it was rodman it
was it was everybody but scotty and here
scotty one of the great players of all
time and i think he just wants to kind
of set the record straight i think he
really got hurt with the last dance he
probably tuned in with his family saying
hey mike's going to be saying some nice
things about me and then next thing you
know mike's roasting scotty there
um
well dan
even myself
when people talk about me they get to
bring up stupid stuff i did
so you know whatever happens happens you
don't get to get mad about it the stuff
that michael said in the last dance was
true
uh like every time they bring up stupid
stuff i did i can't get mad i did have
done some stupid things in my lifetime
but i don't think it was michael's
intention to roll scotty
well like i say i just think that
it seems like if first of all if you
want to say these things just say them
don't put them in a book
that's the only problem i've had with a
lot of these things i i if he wants to
come on dan patrick's show and say some
things i got no problem with that if he
wants to say his opinion
but
when you bring all this stuff up
and you just happen to have a book
coming out
that's what i think is what the problem
everybody is having now
but he's taking on mike right now and
as you know
listen
uh listen that's as big as game hunting
as you can get
i know but you never get that trophy you
you you can't mike doesn't let you put
you know his head on your uh your your
wall that that doesn't happen
i i know but like i say scott is just
trying to sell books i don't think he's
worried about relationships down the
line
our friendship down the line i think
he's just trying to sell books
we're talking to charles barkley of
course hall of famer nba on tnt i
mentioned this stat 57 different players
have scored at least 30 points in a game
so far this season
what do you make of that
it's not fun for me to watch the game to
be honest with you
because
it's just a three-point shooting contest
and
there's times i'm watching the game i'm
like
you got a wide open lane advantage
because they're playing the three take
the ball to the basket
and my biggest problem is we got guys
shooting threes now who can't shoot
and i can say i'm not the old get off my
lawn guy
listen i i tell listen i i i love
basketball basketball has given me
everything in my life
but
now it's like after a game where we
didn't make enough threes i'm like well
if you wasn't making threes you could
have took the ball to the basket
so
it's very interesting to watch
uh but man uh it's it's just a
three-point shooting contest now
trying to figure out and i want to be
fair to the lakers and wait till after
christmas before
i have a good sense of what this team is
going to play like
but it feels like you know russ is
trying
he's trying too hard it feels like what
do you make of the lakers so far first
month of the season
well i think it's interesting uh
they blame everything on russ
you know they belong they belong to they
lost
they lost to oklahoma city twice
they had a 25 point lead in both games
and i'm watching all these foods edius
and jackass on tv the next day blame
rust i'm like yeah they had a 25 point
lead rust didn't do it all by itself
now russ does have to take better care
of the ball
but as i said from the beginning with
all those old geezers out there lebron's
starting to break down
you know those little injuries they
didn't happen five six years ago that
means he's getting older his body is
starting to break down
but
it's still gonna come down to anthony
davis i've said day one if anthony davis
is one of the five best players in the
nba the lakers are gonna be tough to
beat
if he's not one of the five best players
they're not going to be competitive
because he's the only one
that you can't match up with at this
stage of his career
you know to me he should be doing what
magic johnson did
you know you look at you go back and
look at the great laker teens kareem was
the man forever
like lebron and when lebron started
getting older kareem started getting
older then it became magic's team
it should start to be anthony davis team
at this point of his career
anthony why isn't anthony davis more
like the greek freak
he just don't have that that killer
thing
yeah he's uh you know you like
that kid you listen let me tell you
something
giannis and russell westbrook i'll pay
to watch those guys play because as a
fan they give you maximum effort every
single night whether you like russ or
not you got to admire his ability like
i'm gonna give you everything i've got i
might make some mistakes i might miss
some shots but yo man you give me
maximum effort every night that's all i
can ask for as a fan
but
anthony to me he like
and this is it when we're talking about
always comparing guys i says as much as
i love lebron i love lebron he's amazing
but
to me
he don't he didn't have listen michael
and colby they'll kill you
those two got like and it's just a
mindset
and giannis he he is out there like he's
more close to michael and colby and
anthony is more closer to lebron
lebron's a great great player
and he's a really really nice guy
i don't think anybody ever said michael
and kobe were nice guys because they
don't care about that
hey listen and that's not a knock
everybody don't have that killer killer
killer killer instinct
like kobe and michael i could say i've
been in the nba for 37 years
and i've seen a lot of great players
david robinson was a great player he's a
nice man
uh patrick ewing is was a great great
player he's a nice man
carl malone's a nice man john stock's a
nice man michael and kobe listen i don't
think anybody ever said oh man they are
nice guys they out there to kill you
was bird a nice guy
no uh he it's a like uh but he didn't
have that physical ability
like larry beat you with his will and
his mind
but he didn't have the athletic ability
that kobe and michael and lebron and
those guys had larry wields himself and
his team to win
uh that's a great question too same
thing with magic johnson magic johnson
was a great great player but he couldn't
physically impose his will upon you
like kobe and michael could
are you all in on my warriors bandwagon
i think it's too early i'm not you know
dan i don't want to be you know one
thing i hate about these morning shows
not your show these other idiots and
food no like they want to know uh who's
the best team after 10 games i'm like
they play eight or two games that's like
you said like i'm watching these shows
you're like who's the nfl mvp i'm like
dude they play like six games nobody
cares let it get it'll it'll come out
why do you keep watching these shows you
hate
because i'm number one i need to know
well number one you got to get up in the
morning dan
and secondly
it's fun to work out
uh and watch something i mean there's
nothing else on
from six in the morning until noon
okay what drives you crazy though when
you watch these shows that makes you
yell at the tv
well you know i hate scale bayless
i hate him more than anything in the
world but you watch
uh i watch shannon and because
listen in fairness i need to know what
because dan i'm coming on your show
i need to like
seriously you know i love you you're one
of my favorite people i mean i mean
you're a coward on the golf course and
dan let me tell you something
you ain't got no chance to ever beat me
again
i'll come to your house i'll come
wherever you at you ain't never going to
beat me in golf again and i say it never
ever
you know if we had played for money all
these years
you wouldn't have any money
no so i i was i gave you chair you're a
charity case
come on dan i have been through
uh when i was a really good player
i was the worst player in the world but
i'm back now brother i'm back now with a
vengeance okay but i don't like this
front runner attitude here
because
you know that no no no no no no no no
i'm not gonna let you get away with that
hey when i was crappy on the golf course
y'all trashed me for 30 years yes you
did i tried
hey listen
i told you not to play i told you not to
play i tried to help you
what else are old fat people going to do
what else the old fat people gonna do
okay
what does shaq do
make commercials
he makes money
he makes money
hey listen i'm an old fat dude i just
want to play golfing fish every day i
love relaxing doing nothing but i got my
superpowers back i'll play anybody
anytime anywhere okay what's your
handicap here uh tiger
i'm uh i'm i'm a 10 i'm back to a 10 now
um i'd like to see the index i like to
see your card there i'm back to a tear
down yeah i'm just telling you i don't
trust you
i don't trust you
what are you gonna do to show from my
house we've been saying that for 30
years but aren't you in philadelphia
no i'm in arizona oh okay
dad i don't do cold weather brother
um
i still hey and i i've never let cameras
in my house that's my private sanctuary
but when they had the super bowl out
here a few years ago
we talked about doing it in my backyard
i know
yeah we can do i'll tell you what we'll
set up on my tennis court
i bring all the refreshments
we'll get drunk as hell and do great tv
what do you have three bedroom two bath
is that what you got there
five bedrooms five baths
guest house tennis court driving range
swimming pool then
i got a lot of money i ain't gonna
regret this i need to spend it
hey
super bowls in arizona next year
come on we can do one of the shows then
i'm not leaving all this money for my
freedom
all right if i listen if i can go to
vegas one last trip before i kill over
lose some money then burn the rest i'll
be the happiest person in the world
can i be a pallbearer
oh i'm not i'll do i don't do funerals
hey i told him to burn my fat ass up and
put me in these alabama
then i'm seriously i'm gonna get
cremated
funerals suck i'm gonna get cremated i
want my ass to spread over leeds alabama
i don't i know no i don't want to hear
no crying i don't want anybody first of
all i don't want people up there telling
stories i know i don't want that i just
wait listen i've had a great run
just play get my burn my fat ass up but
that that's listen i've always wanted to
be skinny
hey
hey
sisley put my ass in uh there's a lake
in my hometown called lake purdy i want
my ass to spread in lake purdy and
everybody go out and have a celebration
but you don't want to have a wake we're
not allowed to
like hell no
oh come on they're being well dan nobody
want to sit around and look at somebody
who's dead listen i'm not trying to be
marbled or ever
i don't believe in that crap and don't
put me in the ground somewhere i'm not
go hey i'm not going to go visit people
i never get there they're not in the
ground folks don't go visit cemeteries i
think that's crazy what if we stuff you
could we do something like that
no no no dude just break throw me in
that oven
put it on there then just spread the
asparagus man put me down dan i'm good
with that
great to talk to you
always man hey you guys have a have a
great weekend
and thanks for having me dan hi buddy
great to talk to you again that's
charles barkey hall of famer inside the
nba on tnt